[Applause]
we've come so far from that very first
small step for a man but not as far as
our dreams will take us within a decade
or two Mars will be our next destination
but are we ready to survive it this is
how to survive on Mars this red planet
is our neighbor in the solar system but
it has none of the components that make
life possible here on earth it's full of
radiation and too cold for liquid water
it has an atmosphere we can't breathe
and soil that we can't grow anything in
its gusts of wind comes close to what we
classify as hurricanes here on earth and
now we want to make it our new home how
can you prepare yourself for this
mission what should you bring with you
and what's your best strategy for coming
back alive I honestly doubt Matt Damon
could have survived being stuck on Mars
all by himself but
luckily for you we've put together a
list of five tips that will help you to
get through it
number one become prepared before you
can even board the spaceship NASA will
be testing and training you for months
and I'm not just talking about your
physical strength your mental health is
just as important you're going on a very
long trip where you'll be stuck in small
quarters with the same people if NASA's
tests have shown anything it's that
you'll get irritated with your
crewmembers so you'd better have a high
degree of agreeableness a strong desire
to work together and good humor and if
you lied on your resume about how well
you handle high-pressure situations the
tests will show me number two pack up
your gear Mars isn't going to welcome
you with open arms
it's atmospheric pressure is so low that
it'll make your blood boil inside your
body it's night temperatures drop from a
comfortable 20 degrees to minus 153
degrees
its surface is coated with dust so
finely grained that it would damage your
lungs if you inhaled it top that all off
with winds rampaging at 97 kilometres an
hour and a whole lot of cosmic radiation
well you get the picture if you just
crash on Mars with only your spacecraft
and a single suit on your back you won't
last longer than one hour if you want to
survive on Mars you'll need multiple
spacesuits that will reflect all the
radiation keep you warm and provide you
with oxygen and sufficient pressure
you'll also need a craft you'll live in
until a bigger habitat is constructed
and vehicles to take you on your Martian
adventures
number three bring your food the soil on
Mars is a very fine powder like dust
covering the basalt rock that's
precisely the opposite of fertile if you
want to grow anything on the Red Planet
you'll need a ton of solid biomass waste
yeah you'll be collecting all your poop
and all your crew members poop and then
you'll plant potatoes or whatever it is
you want to grow in that mass of people
you could eventually start growing some
lettuce garlic and even potatoes but
you'd better stock up with supplies
before you go on the mission and make
sure those supplies will last you for at
least a year that's how long it takes
for another crew to arrive to Mars
number four
don't forget about water Mars is too
cold to have liquid water instead it has
its water frozen as the polar ice caps
of course you can't bring a year-long
supply of water with you all the way to
Mars but here's what you can do some
initiatives suggest ways that you could
extract water in Martian conditions one
of them being an aerogel developed by
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory this
silica substance is meant to warm the
surface of Mars by 65 degrees that's a
way to melt Martian water ice and have a
supply of drinking water as well as
water for irrigation or you could filter
your pee as astronauts on the
International Space Station table
number five be useful this should really
be the number one tip on this list but I
wanted to leave this hard truth to the
end you can't go to Mars simply because
you won some contest or paid big bucks
to join the crew you'll have to be a
trained astronaut with at least one
master's degree in engineering
biological or physical science computer
science or mathematics you could have a
master's in botany but you can't be a
tourist if you fit the description your
typical day on Mars will include tending
to plants maintenance checks and repairs
to all the water electrical and
filtration systems that keep your
habitation operational and some light
exploration of the planet you'll be
sending updates to earth-based agencies
and you'll most likely be missing earth
very much Mars isn't for everybody it's
just hostile the process of making Mars
our new home will be very slow but
theoretically it's doable we've already
tried it on our other show called
what-if and now we're here to help you
survive whatever awaits you
you